[Music]
from the studio that colonized your
childhood comes the latest culture to
get strip mined by disney for anything
they can turn into movies merch or theme
parks but these days they've been doing
it respectfully with great characters
and catchy songs so truce
and kanto
return to columbia back in the 19
something or others and stay in the
magical family's magic casita a house
that's always listening the house isn't
going to decorate itself
sorry with a cousin who can hear a pin
drop no one has to know
[Music]
a cousin who controls an army of spies
the rats told me everything and a creepy
uncle watching through the walls how
long have you been back here truly the
worst place on earth to be a teenage
girl and me teenage girl mirabelle the
family's only muggle aside from the
standard disney power that lets you
freeze time
she'll battle high expectations
inadequacy and literal burnout
as she struggles to understand why she
wasn't granted a special gift though if
you ask me her gift is living rent-free
in a house that cleans itself while her
siblings get a lifetime sentence of
community service when they turn five
will you serve this community
mira you have it so easy let it go
that's what i'm always saying bro
smuggle a pin and pad into the theater
because there's so many characters in
this one even the characters can't keep
track of the characters wait who's
assistant who's the cousin there's so
many people how do you give a monster
okay okay as a magic candle gives three
old generations a super power until it
ran out of good ideas and started
handing out curses there's louisa who's
super strong great mom can heal the sick
with food awesome peppa's mood changes
the weather that's more like a
punishment though right you're lucky
it's not a hurricane antonio can talk to
animals which is cool until you hear
your friends eat your other friends
don't eat those
this guy can shapeshift what's that good
for crime stop pretending you're dolores
so you can have seconds
worth of shot dolores has super hearing
in a house with two married couples
definite curse bruno can see the future
but mostly just the bad stuff big time
curse and isabella grows flowers come on
candle get your head out of your wax if
you can't think of anything useful just
magic up some birth control
gasps as their once perfect home starts
to become a crack house now it's up to
mirabelle to discover why and defeat the
evil villain at the center of it all not
bruno he's just lazy you know the
mountains around the encounter are
pretty tall and uh like i said free food
and everything
no the real antagonist in this movie is
getting castlet by your grandma the
magic is strong everything is fine there
is nothing wrong with la casa madrigal
the magic is strong and so are the
drinks not exactly jafar level evil but
there's something off about this abuela
if that is your real name
oh it is your real name just grandma in
spanish well that must have been hard to
grow up with
so enjoy a story about complex emotions
and long simmering resentments then all
get tied up neatly in a few minutes tops
maybe i overdo it but if you're too
stubborn to just i see you and i hear
you
but who cares when the colors are this
bright the dancing is this fluid and the
music is this catchy because lin-manuel
is keeping the hot streak alive with one
heart-rending oscar-nominated song and
three other jams that you'll be singing
for months like the magic powers that
gloss over serious issue song
[Music]
[Music]
how you
[Music]
if she's repressed imagine how i feel
mom what this family means is therapy
my whole family needs some therapy
i guess i'm lucky that all i have is
anxiety cause this family needs all the
therapy
oh crap the lin-manuel is trying to tell
us something song
[Music]
but he can't take a break
money's great
and the song that you'll not be named
please don't start singing
[Music]
it begins
[Music]
musical tapeworms
so insane
[Music]
please don't start singing blue no
please no no
we can't stop singing bruno
starring
no door of the explorer
luigi's mansion
swole team six
instagrammer the wrong kid adored
the changeling no fart goes unheard
where video game turkey legs come from
gail weathers jose exotic
another easy paycheck for alan tudyk and
it took disney this long to realize
capybaras are adorable hello
disney's haunted by your tragic past
mansion
when does disney have against bruno's
your blues
bruno
today is tuesday
dante esta la biblioteca
happy 25th to cash manuka 2 gringotts
steakhouse
i serve only one master and his name is
jeff goldblum
we'll be back after these messages